STEPHANIE WONG: So far
for our Hipster Shop app,
we have Istio set up with our
Kubernetes engine cluster,
and we've set up some
intelligent traffic management
using Istio.
But how do I monitor
each Istio component?
KRISTIN AYALA: Well,
like many of our services
on Google Cloud,
Stackdriver can integrate
and monitoring your Kubernetes
cluster and Istio components.
STEPHANIE WONG: Ah, Stackdriver,
another hipster favorite.
KRISTIN AYALA: Yes.
Let's jump into it, and I'll
show you how it all looks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRISTIN AYALA: Stackdriver
combined with Istio
reduces the
complexity of managing
micro-service
deployments by providing
a uniform way to log, monitor,
and trace your application.
Once the Istio
service is set up,
we can first visit
the metrics explorer.
From here, type Istio
in the Find Resource
Type and Metric section.
Numerous additional metrics
from the Istio service
are now available.
Let's look at Client
Request Count.
This metric shows the
number of client requests
sent by the service.
On the right side,
we see a graph
with numerous service
records and details
when we mouse over them.
On the left side,
we have filters
to narrow down or combine
data elements on the graph.
Let's get a mean of
the client request
count for all the services.
Wow, that looks better.
Not only are we able to
view individual metrics,
but with Istio, we are able
to see how our services are
connected from a top-down view.
Let's visit the
topology section.
If we mouse over
the front end, we
are able to see specific
services it communicates with.
Depending on the data made
available with the service,
things like latency
may also appear.
This becomes especially useful
for large-scale projects
with hundreds of
connected services.
Additionally, if you are curious
about how a particular service
performs, you can drill into
each section from the Overview.
Here we can see the
service level specifics,
including the individual request
count we looked at earlier.
Under the service
section, it gives us
yet another view of
Istio data this time with
a per service detailed
view of all the metrics.
Date and time filters are
provided at the top of the page
to narrow down the metrics
to exactly when you
want to see your data.
Just below that,
there are three tabs--
SLOs, Metrics, and Diagnostics.
The SLOs tab provides things
like compliance, indicators,
and errors to help assess if a
specific service is within SLO.
The next tab, Metrics,
provides the same details
we saw on the drill down
with the topology view.
The third tab,
Diagnostics, provides us
with service level, trace
data, errors, and logs.
Here we are able to
select filters and see
which specific functions
within the service
are slowing things down.
On the top, we can see the
parameters and values called
within the specific traces.
On the right-hand
column, triggered events
from service level
policies appear.
Each of these sections links
to respective Stackdriver page
for further details.
Here, we can see the
expanded trace lists
along with timing data
to get a better overview.
Data doesn't always
look perfect.
To help test
configurations, we can
use [INAUDIBLE]
files, such as this,
to mess up those pretty
graphs and see how
our application handles faults.
By calling this
file using Kube CTL,
we are able to halt 50% of the
traffic in our shipping service
by giving a 505 error.
More details on fault injection
with Istio are linked below.
STEPHANIE WONG: Seeing
that service graph really
adds clarity to how each
Istio component interacts.
I love it.
KRISTIN AYALA: Yes, Stackdriver
makes it really easy
to monitor, trace, and debug
your Istio applications.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Well, I can't wait
to see what else you have
in store to integrate
with an Istio-enabled
Kubernetes cluster.
Don't forget to like, comment,
and subscribe to stay up
to date with our next episode.
KRISTIN AYALA: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]